they tested a low-carb group and a
low-fat group
they equated calories and protein in
each group so they're eating the same
amount of calories same amount of
protein
and then they just wanted to see which
group resulted in more fat loss
and they couldn't find any difference
graeme tomlinson welcome to the show
thanks for having me how are you doing
i'm well man i went to leeds and back
today
and this is how down regulated the
stimulus of my life has become
i've spent so much time in the same four
walls that the journey to leeds and back
actually felt like an adventure i spent
three and a half hours in the car
and and literally felt like i've gone on
holiday
well talking of holidays it doesn't look
like that's going to happen anytime
anytime soon um yeah it's been a funny
funny year hasn't it with lockdown and
to be honest i don't know about you but
it hasn't actually affected me
that much because like yourself i'm kind
of working from home anyway
and the only thing that's changed for me
is not being able to go
abroad or get on a plane to go to london
or something like that
yeah and obviously obviously not seeing
family and friends
is um not great but yeah in terms of
work everyday life
it's it's not that much different no
start it was actually quite nice
dude it's a bit much now i said i said
that every introvert
it's now their dream you know you don't
have to go and do all of the social
events that you never enjoyed
but i'm and perfectly fine working on my
own doing my solitary stuff
but after 12 months of being
in exactly the same location even i
like and if i'm starting to push it then
for the people that are listening who
are really social and
and used to going out and spending tons
of time with their friends and
it it really is challenging so yeah man
i'm looking forward even if we can't go
abroad i'm just looking forward to
to lead west yorkshire not somehow
feeling like i should be grateful for it
i should be grateful for the [ __ ] a1
you know i mean like this isn't
this isn't me taking it taking a trip to
somewhere exotic anyway anyway
we are going to talk about fat loss
today you are the fitness chef on
instagram
you are red pilling people on how to
really understand calories from foods
what they think is happening what's
actually happening in the truth behind
weight loss
what are the most common errors that you
see people making when they're trying to
lose weight
um i think one of them is is not
understanding what you you were just
saying there understanding
that hey you need a calorie deficit so
consume
less calories than you use each day
to lose fat that is the principle that
is not a method that is literally the
only physiological way you can lose fat
so
unfortunately unfortunately it's not
sexy enough to be marketed so
it kind of misses a lot of people so a
lot of people start trying to lose fat
without even understanding
that basic element that's required um
and so once you start from there and you
start going on
an extreme intervention like low carb or
keto or whatever it is and you don't
understand about
calorie balance you're almost setting
yourself up for failure
another one would be even if you do
understand that you need the calorie
deficit
is making it unsustainable in other
words having it ultra restrictive and
aggressive so
for myself i know my maintenance
calories would be around about
2 200 400 and for my activity level
and you know for the average female it
could be
i don't know 1700 to 1900 but
when they go on these calorie counting
apps like myfitnesspal
it asks them how much weight you want to
lose gives them an option
and it'll be like one pound a week two
pounds three pounds of course are going
to select
the biggest amount of weight loss why
wouldn't you i would do that um
but unfortunately what that does is is
that formulates a calorie target of
something like a thousand to twelve
hundred calories which
yes it's a calorie deficit but it's
quite extreme
and unsustainable um you'll be very
hungry
and it'll be difficult to adhere to it
and the most important thing
about fat loss isn't the calorie deficit
it's actually adhering to the calorie
deficit
over a period of time so those are
probably the two
main things and i would say that are
very basic for people to understand
what's the maximum weight loss per week
that you think people should comfortably
aim for
so no they're not a pro bodybuilder they
haven't got some
mma fight coming up yeah that's a
a very interesting question because you
could easily answer that and say
it doesn't matter because it's just a
number on the scale now
people do like to measure their weight
loss progress by weighing themselves
every week and
over a period of weeks and months if you
lose body weight
you will definitely be losing body fat
right but
if i was to weigh myself today and then
next tuesday
i could have lost weight but it might
not be body fat i could have gained
weight
it might not be body fat um so from that
perspective
i would just say if you do want to
measure a number i would say one pound a
week
the minimum you know the minimum and
that's the most achievable thing that
you can do
if you do that every week for a year
that's a lot of weight
but unfortunately people don't tend to
think with that mindset they're thinking
holiday in two weeks have to lose it all
by then
or getting married in two months i've
done nothing about it and now i'm gonna
you know
do a juice cleanse or something like
that so something crazy
even one pound a week is 3500 cals right
which is a 500 calorie per day deficit
which is still quite a significant
deficit to be and if you think that
for a girl on an absolute top end they
would maybe get 2 000 calories
that's a quarter you're talking about a
quarter every single day
not including a refeed not including a
cheat day
and that's just to break one pound half
a kilo
a week and even if you had weeks where
you didn't lose fat you know it can
happen things come up you know
well in a few months time few nights out
hopefully um
and so even if it was half a pound a
week that's still a lot of weight over a
period of time
um but we just don't think like that
when we're starting out a lot of people
because
the solutions that are in front of us
are shiny
and promise the outcome you know you
will look like this in
a month or two weeks that's what people
are focusing on
and unfortunately and that's why they're
kind of diving into these
ultra restrictive calorie deficits and
which
to be honest are fantastic for boxers
and
you know they want to cut weights
dramatically um but not for the average
person who
you know hopefully enjoys things like
bread and
donuts and lasagna things like that
to the uninitiated that are listening
how is it that you can still get to eat
bread and sugary foods and lasagna
and still lose weight is there such a
thing as a good food or a bad food
so there can't be such a thing as a good
food or a bad food food is simply
different
um again that could just be my opinion
but objectively
looking at say a chocolate bar or an
avocado
if the quantities of both were 200
calories
we can see that the avocado was
micronutrients
a little bit of fiber in there
beneficial fats but still 200 calories
that's the energy value
and that's the thing that's related to
the body fat at the end of the day
the chocolate bar will have 200 calories
and probably
minimal nutrients and certainly no fiber
so yeah i mean you can you can weigh it
up and i think i always try and get
people to understand
the two different facets so energy the
calories in foods
and also the nutritional value and the
fiber value things that are going to
benefit your overall health and
influence your your next decision
you know if something satiates you and
fills you up it's more likely that
you're
or sorry less likely that you're going
to eat more calories than you should
so i think you know this good and bad
thing
i think it's a little bit pedantic of me
to say nothing can ever be good or bad i
think it's more a case of
there can be a a good or a bad overall
diet
aka one that supports you or doesn't
support you
but as an individual choice like one
meal out of a week is one meal out of 21
meals you know if that was something
that was
double the calories than you normally
have it's not going to make much
difference
as long as all the other meals are kind
of still supporting you so
yeah i it's one of my kind of pet hates
is when i say people saying i've been
good or i've been bad
because what it does is when when people
eat something like a pizza or a
chocolate bar they
feel guilty um of course if they were
doing that every day
potentially it's not very it's not going
to be optimal for them
but if they're doing it in moderation
and they understand more about the food
they're eating
it's a lot easier for them to make
informed decisions about what they're
eating
so getting on to some of the biggest
myths of fat loss there's been
if if this is the case because i
remember when if it fit your macros
came out ish came out came out publicly
um
the launch of it yeah and that was what
maybe like
2011 2012
i'd say kind of the back end of the zero
that sort of
timing if it fit your macros came out
everyone had been in the car backloading
for a long time then carbonite came out
and then it was just it's any calories
bro
so if it's been it's any calories bro
for the best part of a decade now nearly
nearly 10 years
of the if it fits your macros world
why have we seen stuff like keto and
intermittent fasting and slimming clubs
and
all this sort of stuff before we get
into trashing them which is going to be
great
why how have they come up is it just
repackaging things in a sexier way
that's easier to market
yeah i mean i think the keto diet came
around
initially to treat epileptic kids you
know nothing to do with body composition
um and low carb diets could be seen to
be
advantageous for treating people with
type 2 diabetes
but these things always tend to morph
into
fat loss because everybody wants to lose
fat
because we are a nation and to be honest
the whole planet
is quite obese now um it's naturally
going to move into that because that's
what people are seeking
i guess you know that's my kind of
that's how i kind of think it's
happening
um yeah i think like the it's all
calories bro
it's an interesting one because
obviously you've got the three different
macronutrients you've got the protein
which is is just great for any fitness
goal that you have it's going to help
you build muscle
it's it's probably going to help you
lose fat as well because you burn more
calories when you digest that compared
to carbs and fats so
over time that's that's going to help
you lose weight
because your energy expenditure is
higher um
but i guess like the low carb for me it
probably just
kicked off when well in my opinion
everything started when i started going
on social media but it could have been
before that in blogs
but yeah you have low carb and keto
zealots
that use the the kind of insulin
hypothesis
to get past their argument or to support
their argument instead of what is that
what's
the insulin hypothesis well it's the
idea that that hormones will dictate
fat loss instead of energy balance um
so the more the insulin rises the more
fat because it's the fat loss
storage hormone sorry the fat storage
for
hormone um it's basically going to
result in more fat loss and they just
ignore the fact that
despite the fact that that's true
insulin is there it does occur
it's definitely a massive part of the
process the
the end result is defined by total
energy in
versus total energy out that's what it
takes it
um so yeah it's kind of like
cherry-picking a segment of the process
between
somebody eating calories and it being
metabolized
and turned into fat tissue they're chick
they're they're checking that one part
of the
process and just using that and that's
where you get the low carb thing from
that's where you get
anti-sugar from you know the sugar one's
a little bit more vicious
in the sense that people claim that it
is you know poisonous or
turn straight to fat all these kind of
ludicrous claims are just not supported
anywhere in evidence
um and then you get the other side of it
whereby if somebody enjoys
low carb diets they can do without
things like pasta
bread um you know any type of high sugar
food
and it helps them achieve their goals
fantastic
but the problem comes when people are
trying to lose weight and they enjoy
those foods and they feel they have to
cut them out and it's just unnecessary
there's
there's no kind of evidence there in
fact all the evidence
goes against what some of these
hypotheses are saying you can look at
things like the
rice reduction diet experiment where
participants
ate 95 of their calorie intake from
rice fruit and fruit juice pretty much
all carbohydrates
um in there and they were in an
aggressive calorie deficit
you know you certainly wouldn't uh
administer the calorie deficit they were
on
but guess what they lost an average of
like 63.9 kilos across
participants because they were in a
calorie deficit um and that was just
eating purely carbs
and then we have another meta-analysis
from
two or three years ago where they tested
two different groups a low-carb group
and a low-fat group
um they equated calories and protein in
each group
so they're eating the same amount of
calories same amount of protein and then
they just wanted to see
which group resulted in more fat loss
and they couldn't find any difference
in fact i think they found an
insignificant difference between low fat
resulting in more fat loss than
the low carb diet group and that was a
meta-analysis
of lots of different studies out there
so there's there's two examples
of quite reliable research to
just i mean if you say that to somebody
who
it's like an anti-carb zealot
they can't say anything to that it's
like well how can you arg
how did that happen then if what you're
arguing is true
um so yeah but what do they say to that
what's the answer to that
uh well to be honest the conversations i
have with
low carb zealots are normally my
instagram comments section
and they will come out with all these
claims
and i will probably come back with well
can you cite some evidence
and they'll probably come back with some
sort of study that's been done
because people talk about showing
evidence but actually there's a lot of
bad evidence out there as well like
anybody could do a study and publish it
that's why you kind of want to look for
systematic reviews or
reviews or meta analysis because it's
like
all the studies done on any given
question such as
do carbs make you fat you're more likely
to get a more reliable answer if you
look at that kind of data as opposed to
just one individual study that was done
in 1993
which supports your bias and there you
go that supports it but i'm saying well
hang on yeah but what about
what about this you know i see what
you're saying there with that evidence
but
can you not appreciate what i'm showing
here nope
why do you think it is why do you think
it is that people are so
patriotic about the
dietary team that they're on it's crazy
it's definitely getting worse
i think is that right because i i don't
i i only see
these discussions when i observe you
or james smith or diren or
any other of the vanguard of like
british argumentative blokes
on the internet killing killing the
dreams
of some marketer out there um i i only
ever observe it happen right so i only
get to see a tiny little sliver but you
reckon it's getting worse
yeah i just think people's ability to
even debate you know quite happily if
somebody wrote a comment saying
yeah but i don't agree with that
respectfully because
look at this and this and this i would
be more than happy to admit that i was
wrong if i had kind of jumped the gun on
something or
not appreciated the other side of
someone's argument
um the fact i've maybe done that in the
past um
but just it's more the argumentative
kind of nature of people's comments it's
more like they're just
angry and they want to project that
instead of them actually wanting a
discussion that's going to help
either one of us and so yeah it's very
difficult to communicate with people
like that but
it is tribal i think it possibly started
with
with veganism you know because my
sister's a vegan
and you know she's a nice person
but but you will get people out there
who are just wanting to project
almost an authoritarian manner how
everybody should be doing things
and they just can't take it when someone
else wants to do something different
because they're entitled to you is that
not the same way as it is with
everything at the moment though
so think about the patriotism that you
see between people's political parties
at the moment or towards a social cause
or towards a particular type of
injustice or whatever it is
i think this is a rabbit hole we don't
need to go down but
the collapse of grand narratives the
lack of a religion to hang on to the
fact that you don't have any greater
sense of purpose it's a meritocracy you
are your job you are your possessions
you are your follower account
people are looking for their new gods
and they appear to be finding them
inside of a diet book
at the moment or a social media account
or a plethora of
a small kind of niche of social media
accounts that's a great point
you know as um you know our kind of age
group
i certainly a lot of my mates aren't
religious and probably my parents aren't
religious either so it probably
stretches to people who are kind of in
their 50s or 60s as well
so yeah it's it could be that as human
beings we're always
craving something to follow something to
believe in that's why
like i support liverpool at football
stupidly sometimes
um this season anyway it's like why did
i pick them and why do i get so worked
up when i watch them on tvs
you know looking at it objectively it's
just a football match
you know if they win or lose it has no
impact on my life at all
and yet it does emotionally exactly
i had a sociologist on the show a couple
of months ago a guy called rob henderson
who's a good buddy
and he told me that up until 2012
supporters of the democratic party in
america
loved their party more than they
disliked the other one and that was the
same for republicans as well
but after 2012 people that voted
democrat
voted democrat because they hated the
other party more than they liked their
own
well literally the the compulsion that
we have now is an in-group
out group relationship where all that
we're bothered about
is not being the out group as opposed to
actually being the in group and i think
what you see here is we just
want to feel like we're a part of a team
a part of a crowd
like if you're some 39 year old
triathlete club level triathlete
who is adamant that low carb is the way
to go and all
of your waking hours are spent
researching the different type of
bike clip mechanism that you're going to
use and the new type of shoes and you're
waiting for race weekend to come around
that's your world and if you are just as
patriotic about that it feels when
someone says yeah
mate but it's any calories bro like low
low carb
is for people with epilepsy and type 2
diabetes it doesn't matter
that doesn't just feel like a critique
of the food that you put in your mouth
it feels like an
existential threat against your ego
feels like someone's trying to destroy
your identity
it's an attack isn't it and before
actually
sitting back and thinking about you know
assessing what information that they're
seeing
it's an immediate impulse reaction isn't
it to go and comment and say
you're wrong you know and it's um i
think we all do it but
to some degree but i certainly notice it
uh on social media with when it comes to
nutrition i've had posts you know
things like avocado toast versus nutella
toast just displaying the simple facts
there you go you do what you like and
you can have either
you know displaying the facts about
diets and soft drinks
you know that they don't cause cancer
despite all these conspiracies and they
don't make you fat because they've got
zero calories they don't raise insulin
because they've got zero calories
but people are just like yeah but it's
poison bro and it's just like well
what can you say to that you know if it
was poison people would be dying
has there been have there been any
studies that have shown
links with artificial sweeteners in in
rats
um a while ago but in human beings
there's
there's none i mean that's to my
knowledge uh you know i think the most
recent method analysis was done in 2015
um and it had over half a million
participants there and it showed no
carcinogenic properties
within diet soft drinks specifically it
was aspartame so there are other
sweeteners but
aspartame is the one that gets one of
the most researched
yeah food supplements in the world right
it is and it's one of those things that
people will say i can't believe you're
promoting this i'm like
i'm not it's like i can't believe you're
saying it's healthy i'm not there's
nothing optimal about spartan but what
i'm saying is
the research shows it's actually not
harmful if consumed in this dose
if you consumed 100 cans a day that's a
different story
but if you're doing that there's
problems there that you probably need to
get help with there are other
there are other issues bigger than the
aspartame yes i would imagine you would
have other issues
overriding the problem with a spartan if
you're doing that per day
um just having all that bloating for
example purely purely the recycling
issue i think would be would be a big
one okay so that's that's a low carb
what about intermittent fasting
so intermittent fasting can be a short
one it's it's a it's one that's gained
momentum probably in the last
five or six years and and basically
all it is is skipping a meal unless you
are crazy and want to start
doing your interpretation fasting at a
different time most people
would start eating at 12 o'clock and
then finish eating at 8 p.m
or something like that so that they can
combine sleep with some of the fasting
period
but i mean we're all intermittent
fasting as long as we sleep
you know if we're not eating when we're
sleeping we're all doing it anyway so
what's going on is they are skipping
probably
four hours aka breakfast and putting off
until lunch
time um there is no again no research
benefits that that is better for fat
loss
than just having a calorie deficit and
regardless of doing interpretive fasting
or not
you must be in a calorie deficit to lose
fat
so you could have a situation where
someone skips breakfast
doesn't track the calories or isn't
aware of it and consumes in a surplus
from 12 o'clock to 8 o'clock
but they're still doing intermittent
fasting they think it's going to result
in fat loss no
you still need a calorie deficit so if
you like doing that um
i definitely recommend it if you're
somebody who doesn't like breakfast or
never eats breakfast it could be a
really useful way to reduce calorie
intake
but if you're someone who likes
breakfast then it's unnecessary you know
some people might feel dizzy by 10
o'clock if they haven't eaten it just
depends
so yeah that's it um there's also other
purported health benefits like autophagy
so like cleaning out of organs
basically this kind of stuff
and again is there going to be that much
more of that going on so that's
something that occurs when you
don't eat for a while how long is it
going to be
well it will hap i don't know a few
hours um
i haven't actually looked in detail at
the research but if there was
four three or four hours that you
extended that by
is that going to make that much of a
difference to your overall health
if there was that benefit because you're
going to be fasting between say
i don't know 10 p.m 11 p.m and 7 a.m
when you're sleeping
um is there going to be that much more
of a benefit if there
are benefits in the first place that get
purported by delaying that by three
hours or four hours
i'm not sure i guess there needs to be
more research in that but a lot of
people
claim that's one of the benefits of it i
would say
from my experience with intermittent
fasting that a restricted time eating
window
is a good rough tool to assist with
generally not eating as much food now if
you do
if you do a 18 6
fast which is a little bit more
uncomfortable maybe eating between two
2 p.m and 8 p.m it's pretty hard
actually to overeat
in a six hour window you need to be able
to put away especially if you're still
eating relatively whole foods that
aren't hyper calorie dense
to fit what like two to three
big meals in within the space of six
hours
is a fairly difficult task so
i find that tough yeah as long as you
can get through that period um another
thing as well to kind of fly the flag
for intermittent fasting i have found
sometimes when i've done intermittent
fasting that my energy levels are more
stable throughout the morning
that a lot of the time my morning meal
can cause me to feel a bit of a slump
uh sort of mid morning to afternoon
and then without that without that spike
in insulin and glucose
i don't have that sort of oh my god i
need a coffee to stay awake
sensation yeah if that works for you
carry on doing it and you made a great
point about
inadvertently if you have to cram in
three meals to six or seven hours
there's a good chance that you will
probably select foods that are going to
fill you up because you know that
afterwards
you are not going to eat for a while um
you know and you could be then
inadvertently focusing on
or becoming educated on knowing okay
let's have a high protein diet
then because that fills you up let's
make sure that i'm focusing on whole
foods which has always got to be the
basis for any kind of optimal diet
let's increase fiber intake so that i'm
kind of satiated
and i'm not you know having midnight
snacks which
i've been doing during lockdown to be
honest is there any evidence
about timing of food intake
if i eat at carbs at 10 pm at night
am i going to be more likely to store
them as fat because i'm being sedentary
while it's in my stomach
no um there's no evidence out there that
suggests
that the the time that you eat makes any
difference to
the amount of fat that you're going to
store so i think it's just over a
24-hour period the total calories in
versus the energy expenditure and so yes
you
you you know in that basic term that is
it but obviously other things are going
to influence that so if you
starve yourself for seven eight hours
and there's a good chance that you could
overeat or binge
you know i've done it before i've gone
on to libero and i've been absolutely
starving and ordered like two mains it's
a starter dessert and before you know
it's like 5000 calories
and so yeah there could be behavioral
aspects you could look at there but in
terms of just looking at the energy in
versus energy out
it doesn't matter do what you like and
it's the same with the amount of
meals a lot of people were saying six
small meals is better
for your metabolism than your two
massive meals of the same calorie value
again it doesn't matter just do what
suits you um
if you're somebody who likes what about
protein intake
yeah protein intake um i'd always
recommend at least
one gram per kilo of body weights um and
i guess if you are training quite a lot
you could go up to two and beyond um
i think that's something that a lot of
people miss and a lot of people
because it's so because you require for
muscle building
and for fat loss it's going to be
beneficial because it's got a higher
thermic effect
and because behaviorally it's going to
help fill you up
and people often miss that out and maybe
just
concentrate on the calories and maybe
aren't aware of
of the amount of protein that they are
eating and it's actually quite low
and over time it could possibly
contribute to them over eating
um more calories because they're not
feeling cool for example so
yeah um there's also some other crazy
myths that you know
we've seen that people were kind of
saying proteins is bad for you is
smoking and it wrecks your kidneys it's
just
again it's just complete nonsense and
something that the daily mail would just
uh reel out every now and again the
internet the internet tracks some
interesting people
what about the fact that i think i've
seen you
i've definitely seen james post this and
you may have done as well that during
one sitting there's an
upper bound ceiling on how much protein
your body can absorb
yeah it's the there's some there's
various research out there
but 30 grams seems to be the optimal
kind of dose um for for most
people and i guess the average person
or the average male should be consuming
i don't know
12 500 maybe 3 000 calories
a day and female from like 1700 to 2200
so it's going to be
roughly ballpark for most people um
yeah i to be honest it's something
that's still being researched
quite a lot but from the evidence that
i've seen it's
definitely a better idea to aim for
kind of 20 to 40 gram servings of
protein
rather than for example at the end of
the day realizing that you
haven't eaten much protein and you try
and whack in like a hundred grams or
something
um in one meal that's what i'm thinking
about the
related to having an intermittent
fasting window that
inevitably if you've got an upper bound
of about 30 grams that you can absorb
optimally within one sitting how long is
the reset window between that do you
know
uh no i think it would be
no that's something i'll probably have
to have a look at actually um
whether it's relevant for somebody who's
trying to lose
weight i'm not sure but for somebody
who's trying to
build muscle that's definitely something
that they should kind of
think about um but i guess some of the
research that i've seen i don't know if
you've seen some of alan arrogan's
stuff he's sort of talking about every
possibly three to four hours having more
protein
and i think that's certainly in research
showing to be beneficial
for muscle gain for fat loss i'm not
sure
that it really matters how regularly you
have it um
just because for muscle gain you are i
mean
intermittent fasting for muscle gain
might not be the best idea
because you are depleting yourself for a
long period of time and of course
yes you can be losing fat during that
time
for as energy but also muscle you know
muscle's probably the first thing that's
going to be burned
before fat there um so yeah
that's it's interesting yeah it is i was
definitely thinking that i remember
seeing
dan bilzerian talk about his approach to
diet
and his approach to diet is to just have
25 grams of protein every two hours that
he's awake
that's that's all that he does so he'll
have a protein bar then he'll have a
shake then he'll have a little food
i mean when you're constantly surrounded
by when you live
in the maldives or wherever it is he can
just
get tapas presumably on like he just
clicks it
clicks his fingers and some some some
handsome spanish waiter comes over with
with a penny on
and like delivers him some some nice
sort of seafood paella or something like
that
but yeah and that that really stuck with
me because it made me think okay
if there's an upper bound on how much
protein you can absorb if we're focusing
on muscle gain
upper bound and how much protein you can
absorb within a particular window let's
say that it's a couple of hours
and you need to be hitting maybe 160 to
180 to maybe even 200 grams
of protein per day if you're all right
size guy who's been training for a
little while with a bit of mass on and
you're going for that two to sort of two
and a half
grams per kilo of body weight you're
you have to eat you have to consistently
or else you're getting to the point
where right here's
300 grams of chicken breasts that i'm
just gonna have in one meal
and that's going to be what 75 grams
ish of protein between 60 and 75 grams
of protein you're going to get out of
300 grams of chicken breast
yeah maybe more based on what maybe
that's not even going to be absorbed
so it does need to be little and often
for those people perhaps
absolutely and also you i guess for
somebody who's training
quite regularly maybe training twice a
day
having the fuel to fuel that workout it
makes sense you can have protein before
that in a balanced meal
you know within an hour to two hours
afterwards to start recovery
and then later in the day maybe having
an evening meal
so that's things that are kind of meals
that are required
for the training to optimize the
training anyway so
i guess it for a lot of people it would
already be in place
um but certainly for a muscle game it's
something that people probably
yeah it can probably get a bit much it's
like oh my god another meal
you know you know you're probably full
and it's eight o'clock at night
and you know you're trying to you're
trying to get that surplus up there
you're trying to get the protein up
there you realize that you still have
another
30 grams of protein to hit you know
i guess you could have something like a
protein shake but yeah it's
it's tough it's a lot more intricate
gaining muscle than it is
losing fat you think so i mean that
physiologically
but psychologically it's probably harder
to lose fat
for for people who have ingrained
beliefs and grained habits
and it's just about trying to shift that
to change their behaviors over time
whereas for muscle gain it's more yes
you do need to
to appreciate how much protein you're
eating how many calories you're eating
here
what's the progressive overload on your
training stimulus all this kind of stuff
um so that can be psychological as well
but i think it's more kind of
psychological for
fat loss when it comes to that i'd agree
i think
nobody stumbles onto consuming 200 grams
of protein a day
nobody nobody in history has ever
accidentally consumed 200 grams of
protein
the only person that's ever done that is
someone who's going out of their way
to hit a protein target in the same way
as no one ever in history
has accidentally been in a consistent
calorie deficit for a long time
it's not you you have to do it to
achieve the thing that gets you the
output that you want for fat loss or for
muscle growth
it has to be conscious um because it's
just
200 grams of protein is a lot of food
and being in a calorie deficit
is uncomfortable it doesn't just happen
by chance
so it needs to be planned absolutely i
agree uh
what about slimming clubs yeah so
they've been around for a long time
um certainly you know am i allowed to
say that one here that's fine
oh yeah fire away man far away i've got
a lawyer now i've got a lawyer everybody
so if this happens it's james smith's
lawyer
i've covered i got referred to james
smith's lawyer so
he had a he had a legal case a while ago
i don't know what it was if she can
handle
he's obviously got him out of it dude if
this lady can handle the [ __ ] that james
smith throws at
her good point she can deal with you
naming
whoever it is yeah so so weight watchers
in slimming world are the big two
um probably you know i think they're
quite big in america as well but
obviously
huge here in the uk they've been going
for a while when i was doing one-to-one
personal training
a lot of the clients i was getting were
kind of ex-slimming world people who had
kind of had enough
of just turning up and getting weighed
every week and
going home and trying to eat sins and
free foods and all this stuff turning up
the week after
finding out that they've lost weight
don't know why the next week
gained weight and it's all based on that
so it's like it's like a win or lose
arena
and every time they were kind of turning
up you know there were stories of
of people you know not eating all day
because they wanted to lose weight
or you know turning up in swimwear so
that the weight of the clothes weren't
gonna
show on the scales all this kind of crap
and i think yeah the main problem is
just that
a lot of people will say this in the
industry they are just withholding the
principle
from their con from from their members
so that is
the calorie deficit nowhere on their
websites or to my knowledge
at their meetings or weigh-ins do they
communicate this
it's all about telling people to eat a
certain amount of sins
or you can eat unlimited salmon pasta
eggs
which are fairly calorie dense foods you
can eat unlimited quantities of them
and the argument that i always get from
slimming world zealots on my posts is
yeah but nobody does that i'm like i'm
sure
i'm sure nobody does that however this
is what they're saying on their website
you can eat unlimited quantities of this
stuff which can easily result in you
being
in a calorie surplus dude if you gave me
unlimited access to pasta
i could i could put myself in a calorie
surplus
easily yeah oh yeah me too i mean i am
very much of my i'm very much half a
pasta packet per meal which is probably
like 150 grams uncooked maybe more
um so yeah you can imagine someone who's
whose calorie deficit target may be
something like 2
000 calories all of a sudden one meal
they're having 950 calories or something
without knowing it but it's fine because
it's free
it's just this kind of thing there's
just lack of information there
um and it's kind of the same with weight
watchers they use the point system
it's maybe slightly more aligned to
calories i think the points are added up
depending on the calories
in food but it's like why not just do
the [ __ ] calories
yeah this is a mad thing i don't know
why they have to take what is an
already very well established existing
system of measuring and then repurpose
it
into a thing that isn't
it's it's because you know their
marketing team must be
fantastic you know people people there
who are saying right
we know that it's a calorie deficit but
we can call it something else
because we know that people think god
counting calories how tedious and boring
which
probably is you know but let's dress it
up as this and call this
a sin and a speed food and free food all
of a sudden it sounds more sexy
and all of a sudden the measurement
mechanism is just so basic people can
understand it
turn up if they've lost weight success
if they've gained weight no
you're failing but as we know you know
your body weight
is not not reflective of your body fat
you know you could turn up one week and
have eaten
loads of salty foods the night before so
retain more water
and that's the extra weight you might
have actually lost body fat
but gained weight from one week to the
other so that's why the scales over
those short periods of times
aren't overly useful um
and that's yeah that's basically it i
think
it's just yeah it's it's
taking people further away from the very
basic principle that they
need to know um for no reason other than
profits you know and i guess yeah we're
all businesses we want to make money at
the end of the day
but i can't help but feeling that both
of those organizations
their success as a business depends on
their members failure because that means
that they're going to keep coming back
um it's a physio that never wants his
athletes to get well
we see that with chiropractors a lot and
tomorrow there's probably some great
chiropractors
but it's like yeah come here every two
three weeks it's like well hang on a
minute
it's not actually the the bones of the
problem here it's the muscles that keep
pulling bones out of place so as soon as
i leave here
i'm going to be out of joint out joint
again in like i don't know a day
so it's probably that i need to kind of
take care of flexibility
a little bit of strength training here
and there it's going to solve my
problems long term rather than paying 80
quid every three weeks coming
for you to do the same thing um that's
not to say it's not necessary it
absolutely is in a lot of cases
um but that's the kind of yeah similar
to slimming world in that regard
is there a way that i can prioritize
fat loss through foods
when in a calorie deficit yeah there is
so there's no particular foods that will
help fat loss
and there's no particular foods that
will make you gain weight more than
others it's all about the overall energy
however that said we touched upon it
before
pro um foods high in protein so
because protein has a higher thermic
effect
you're talking about every time you have
protein about 30
of those calories that derive from
protein from that food
are burned during digestion so that's an
increase in your energy
expenditure but the net calories is
yeah 30 less than the total calories
that they're actually consuming for
carbs it's around about 10
and for fat it's zero to three percent
is what the
data says which is all the more
interesting that keto zealots
tell you to eat loads of fat and what
they're basically saying is what they
think
is happening is the more fat that you
eat the more fat you'll burn
so they're making that seem more body
fat you'll burn but it's actually just a
dietary fat that you're consuming
wheelbarrows that you're burning
because you've got zero carbs in your
system the carbs are being used as fuel
it's so annoying because
people believe that stuff um anyway off
topic
um other foods like we were saying there
whole foods
you know foods high in fiber again is
going to help
uh make you feel full just like protein
and the more that you're you feel full
the more or the less likely you are
to to overeat um so from that point of
view
you want to look at it from the overall
diet still
um and if you know that for example
you're eating
three meals each of them have 30 to 40
grams of protein
then you can look at it and if you know
you're eating a bunch of micronutrients
it
makes you know it's going to improve
your overall health bunch of fiber it's
gonna
you know improve your digestion you're
taking care of the overall picture
you know that one donut which is 200
calories
as long as it fits your overall calorie
target over a week you know you can be
flexible
that's gonna do nothing bad for your
goal
or your overall health um so yeah the
two things to focus on
would be protein and fiber so upping
them just so that you feel
cooler awesome what about low calorie
diets
uh it depends how low so i guess to lose
fat you
always need to be lower calories than
you're currently consuming
unless you're you know exponentially
increasing your energy expenditure to
create a deficit
um i don't know how low you mean do you
mean like
400 calories a day yeah well i mean it's
we see these right we see these diets on
the internet of girls who are prepping
for bodybuilding shows and have been
told by their coach to
drive themselves into the ground 900
calories or a thousand calories they're
doing morning cardio they're doing
afternoon
weights so yeah i mean
for for that level of competition you
know
i personally would never want to be
involved in that um
but perhaps it's required but for the
average person
that is going to be so miserable um
and you know what happens when you're
miserable you don't want to keep doing
whatever it is you're doing
um and the chances are your behaviors
will go back to what you were doing
before that was
creating the problem so what i always
say to people is
instead of having a calorie target per
day
have it per week so say it was 2000
calories
over seven days that would be 14 000 and
that allows someone the flexibility to
know
that they can go out and go over by
700 calories and the next day it's fine
you know just reduce the next few days
by
100 calories each or something like that
um just to be more flexible but yeah in
terms of low-calorie diets if somebody
really enjoys
eating 500 calories a day and they do
that for a significant period of time
they will lose a lot of body fat
and it will be quicker than if they just
had a gradual say
20 15 calorie deficit which is going to
be slower
but in the long run more likely to be
successful
so there's two options there what does
the evidence say about juicing and detox
well to be honest there's none so it
well
there's not much out there so the claim
is that if you go on a juice cleanse or
a detox you are presumably detoxing your
organs i mean a lot of the
the businesses that promote these things
don't actually know what they're
what they're saying it's just like a
bunch of words saying gonna cleanse
your organs lose weight just all the
buzzwords really
but logic would tell you that unless you
don't have organs
like kidneys and lungs and liver and
skin
unless you don't have those you know you
will be detoxing
naturally anyway that's what they do so
there's no need
you cannot detox and then things like
uh we've seen crazy things like coffee
enemas
um i haven't seen them thank god but
i've heard of them
um jesus yeah that would be i just quit
i just moved to a remote island just
spend the rest of my days looking at the
waves i think if i saw that
but yeah you got all kind of these
things um some of them promoted by
medical practitioners as well
which is hard because they're supposed
to be trustworthy
sources of information and advice um
yeah and you're saying there like a
juice diet
some people do that for fat loss because
it's ultra low
calorie um so if they did it i mean
what's the most popular one
lose seven pounds in seven days so
a lot of people do it for seven days
lose the weight
and then just go back to their old
habits so in a couple of weeks time
they're back to square one you know
completely pointless they've just
shelled out 300 quid for a juicer 200
quid on ingredients
felt like crap [ __ ] themselves at
work
you know all this kind of stuff just
completely ridiculous
um yeah but that's kind of where we are
and that's that's the power of marketing
boom bod is the desiccated power powder
version
of adjustments right the so
the boom bod bases its claim on
glucomannan however you pronounce that
word
which is basically something that
suppresses appetite
and there is some evidence to support
that but is that something that we
really
want to be promoting to essentially
young women maybe teenage
women um because a lot of the
influencers that were
i mean it's not happening so much now
because fortunately so many of us have
called out
dude that was like yeah you remember you
know the final
years ago you know the final scene in
avengers
where the entire you got the wakanda
people you got those big slugs floating
through the air spider-man's back
like thor's just come iron man's leading
the way
like that was what it was like it was
all hands on deck
the lord of the lord of the rings that
the battle of the two towers it was
precisely precise it was um
but god was what a sight to behold i
think it was because
the marketers are obviously just
thinking about who's the target market
who's going to
fall for this yeah and it would be
impressionable young people
you know remember when you were a
teenager i'm the same i would have done
anything
um and unfortunately they're targeting
you know these kind of reality tv
celebrities you know really strong
followings really popular
and there we go um and that's what was
happening but
i don't think they appreciated the
evidence-based community within the
industry and how it was just going to
immediately go for that and not just
evidence just
eviscerate them yeah just people you
know people
who just know when something's wrong
playing common [ __ ] regardless yeah
yeah yeah exactly and and to be honest
the influencers who were promoting it
part of me feels sorry for them because
they probably just didn't appreciate
that either probably not educated in
basic nutrition
and they're just seeing it as they were
caught in the crossfit means to get
money
yeah so i kind of do sympathize with
them a little bit but at the same time
you need to kind of research what you're
promoting at the same time there's not
really
many excuses i've said it on the show
man we we have a lot of sponsors on here
and i don't promote anything if i
haven't used it
athletic greens reached out to me i used
the product for all of 2021 up until
march before i agreed to do anything
with them because i was like i want to
see what this product's like it's not
enough that tim ferriss thinks it's good
i want to actually see if i rate it and
this is the one part that i think is
one of the best externalities of there
being almost like a call
out culture for [ __ ] now with
regards to fitness and diet on instagram
is that the amount of reputational
damage
that you can have that you can give to
someone who continually
compromises on truth to get an
influencer check
if there is that person so a good
example of the reversal of this is
someone like
uh holly hagan yes
so she appears to have almost been a
convert now and she's
part of the evidence-based community
having been on the reality tv side
probably did something similar to a
boombot ad i'm pretty certain i saw her
do it
but then you have other people who are
prepared to compromise
their integrity for a paycheck and
as you roll the clock forward the race
to the bottom is not going to continue
to win because
all of the people are just not going to
buy the product
if they know that this week you're doing
charcoal toothpaste which
doesn't work and next week you're doing
boom bod which
doesn't work and the week after that
you're doing some
one of those waste trainer things which
doesn't work
do you know what i mean like every time
they do that again there's no social
capital left
and from my side i'm more than happy to
see that happen because it means that
for those of us that have decided to go
integrity first
you with your cookbooks like you're not
trying to flog
a special super secret sauce with
pomegranates or whatever way you squirt
it in your eye
like it's just here's some low-calorie
foods here's how to eat them
and the same thing with james like james
is providing what is
in the nicest way possible a really
simple solution like his academy
is just here's some calories here's some
training
here's some accountability go to the
[ __ ] gym like that's all it is that's
all it is
yeah and the thing about it is most of
the time
that's all people need this it just
doesn't sound you can't
like it's hard to do some sort of like
digital ad with that or like a billboard
it's just like common sense or these
these kind of things people just kind of
the way things are now with advertising
you know things have to be extreme to
get noticed
the thing with with my second the second
book still tasty
is all i did was think well what we're
going to do for another book
and it was locked down and my followers
what i did was put a pulsing what's your
favorite recipes
you know and a lot of people come back
with burgers pizzas and toasties and
cheesecakes where i'm like well to be
honest there's easy ways that i can make
these lower in calories
and it's the same volume of food but
it's the same tastes as well
so it's like but possibly 2 300 calories
less
and it's like well that's an
intervention someone could easily make
to lose fat you're still eating all
their favorite stuff
they're not you know buying this
superfood cookbook where they have to
eat edamame beans
wrapped in avocado and cress or
something every morning
sexy you know what it's like it's
looking at all the cookbooks and it's
just like
all these cookbooks even the ones that
are like just meal prep
are all using the lose weight it's just
like get health healthy recipes
lose weight so they're just using all
the buzzwords i'm like hang on a minute
you're not giving any advice for someone
to lose weight there you're just giving
a bunch of recipes that are nutritious
so that's inadvertently good for someone
but if they want to lose weight you need
to actually tell them how
and give them some sort of like
information about it so in each recipe
i'm saying
this is how you save these calories what
i did was change
10 ml of olive oil to 10 sprays of olive
oil spray or
you know changed full fat cheese little
fat cheese it sounds like
it's not cheese isn't coca-cola cheese
to low-fat cheese you know just things
like that they taste the same
but you're eating the same volume so
yeah anyway
good plug there for the book linked in
show notes below what about what about
supplements obviously we've talked about
some of the ones that
aren't worth their salt what supplements
are worth it in your opinion
uh yeah it depends what you mean by
supplements so if whey protein was a
supplement which
i would say it probably is despite the
fact it's
derived from eggs you know it's like it
yeah
it's a supplement let's just call it i
would definitely say whey protein
for the things we've discussed earlier
it can be difficult
to hit that protein target each day and
whey protein provides a really
convenient
and you know there's lots of flavors
tasty solution for that
you can do that within 30 seconds mix up
a protein shake or add it to yogurt
add it to porridge pancakes whatever
it's just really convenient
you don't need it you know you can get
your protein from
chicken eggs fish you know whatever
um but it's just really convenient so
that would be the number one
um you know for supplements i guess it
depends on someone's
situation if somebody was perfectly
healthy and consuming
an abundant variety of different foods
and whole foods
you'd probably say there isn't any need
um but
what i would say is in the uk we are
probably
a lot of us are deficient in vitamin d
just because of the climate
so that is certainly one during winter
months that i take up here in aberdeen i
mean jesus christ january when we were
locked down here i don't think i saw
sunlight for about five
days at one point and this is like yeah
let's take
two vitamin d's every day thanks um
there's one and things like
multivitamins again
are potentially just going to boost
you know boost that functional health
aspect but you don't actually know what
the benefits are you can't see them
you know it's like if somebody keeps
getting colds um
or viruses all the time vitamin c
is is known to kind of counteract that
so they go on high doses of vitamin c
and they don't get colds anymore they
will never know whether it was
their overall lifestyle improvement of
sleep of diet
whatever or that supplement as well so
it you'll never kind of know
um those would kind of be the ones that
i would recommend
um if you're an elite level sort of
training
um you know power lifting and things
like that and obviously elite level
sports
that's kind of out of my level of
expertise so
um i would recommend consulting a sports
nutritionist for that yeah but there
definitely will
will be supplements that will will
definitely give someone that extra one
percent
legal supplement size i mean there's
some illegal ones that will give you far
more than one percent
i would throw into the mix there i'd say
creatine for anybody that's going to the
gym whether you're a guy or a girl
um five grams per day you don't need to
phase it you don't need to cycle it on
and off i think that was a mis
yeah there's a misconception about
cycling on and off
um with creatine but i think most of the
research now suggests that that's
something you don't need to do it can
just be something you take continuously
and as you say there's a yeah there's a
lot of evidence out there
just to to show the benefits of taking
creatine absolutely
um particularly if you're looking to
build muscle you know
absolutely yeah yeah so creatine i would
also personally for me i added in a
greens drink
so i find i mentioned earlier on
athletic greens it's just awesome it
just means
no one's eating enough vegetables like
not even the vegans
no one not even the fitness chef himself
he's eating enough vegetables so yeah
man like
that that but that would be my whatever
it is like a six-car garage
and you can add in funky stuff there's
some good fat burners out there
green tea tablets i've used for years
omega 3 sixes and stuff are good
but i wonder something i think a lot of
a lot of the problem is things like fish
oils
depending where you get them from you
need to make sure that the dosage is
actually going to be effective
so a lot of the things that you get in
the supermarkets
the dose is so low is that right that
yeah and
the that's it tends to be the more
expensive
supplements you get and you maybe have
to go to a specialist source
you know and pay over the odds but
you're going to get a higher dose
of those fish oils and so it's kind of
like
yeah if you had two groups and someone
took fish oils a
and then there was another more kind of
potent fish oil for group b
over time be interesting to see you know
what kind of reactions they would have
to that because there's definitely
discrepancies
in the dosage between between these
things and people don't understand that
it's not
commonly known even myself i'm kind of
looking at it in the supermarket going
yeah
fish oil supplements good i don't eat a
lot of oily fish maybe once every couple
of weeks
which you should probably do a little
bit more regularly than that so i'm like
yeah fish oil
i'm looking at it going maybe you need
to have about eight of these instead of
two
what about um that's something to
consider what about foods what
food uh types what what the best foods
that you found to make dieting less
painful
everyone's got a couple in their back
pockets that they like to rely on
to be honest um in my personal
experience
my diet
to be honest i would just say make what
you're eating tastes good
because there was there's that kind of
mindset of
chicken broccoli and rice for so many
years it was almost like a bodybuilding
staple wasn't it
um yeah make what you're tasting good
because you can eat anything um i would
definitely say
unless you're vegan or vegetarian
focusing on
lean sources of protein is gonna
kill two birds with one stone it's gonna
get your protein level up there and it's
not gonna
result in excessive calories so
something like a chicken breast 100
grams of that you're talking about 100
to 130 calories if it's not got the skin
on
compared to like a steak which would be
a lot more than that
um but obviously that's providing a high
level of protein and protein as well so
lean sources of of meat plenty of fruits
and vegetables
um you know filling your plate with with
vegetables is
is a great way to kind of reduce the
calorie content increase the volume
same with fruit as well if you're
somebody who's trying to lose fat
and love snacking all the time but
you're snacking on things like
millionaires shortbread which is like
150 calories
per centimeter it's not quite that bad
but something like that you know yes
have that
known again but having some high volume
foods like fruit or
low fat greek yogurt maybe a scoop of
whey protein in there
you know those types of things are gonna
make you full
hopefully and provide you with
micronutrients for your overall health
but also get the volume
up so that you're you're you're feeling
full and you're less likely to eat for
longer
which is going to support a calorie
deficit but have you tried um
have you tried this lindals kvarg
stuff it's a it looks like a yogurt
but it's technically a
um cottage cheese a flavor a sweet
flavored cottage cheese
um so you can get it like quark yeah
it's very similar to quartz so some of
them are cottage cheese and some of them
are quarks
um dude they have completely
revolutionized the yogurt game
with this i'll have to try them as do
you get them in all the supermarkets
yeah
they're everywhere but as this certainly
has a big a big group of them
so skier have now brought out
an increased protein small version of a
pot
and it's the macros on the back of it
it's like
harry potter's cupboard or something
absolutely insane
so it just tastes it tastes like a thick
nice yogurt
but is zero grams of fat like 0.5 or 1
grams of carbs
and 18 grams of protein i'm like this is
just about 100 calories
this is just a protein supplement it's
mad so
the ones that taste good so it's like
you're going to eat that and presumably
you get it flavored as well oh yeah dude
they've got they've really gone quite
sophisticated with is that lemon
cheesecake flavor there's strawberry
shortbread flavor
all with these macronutrient profiles
it's i'm telling you so if you are
considering
you're getting back into the gym you're
thinking right i need to i need to get
back on my diet
that's such a good hack um charity
popcorn low calorie popcorn i think is
such an easy one
um it does help to fill you up quite
easily i'm not a massive fan of
the zero calorie or low calorie jelly
it's just something to do with the
texture of that when i'm hungry
it's so slimy and it doesn't feel too
good but i know that a ton of buddies do
that
nando's sauce as sources go
is about as low calorie as you can get
whilst
still being not being a low calorie
source does that make sense
i know what you mean yeah i'm a big
advocate of nando's sauce i'm putting it
on
chicken a lot very regularly medium
though
i'm a bit i'm a bit i haven't elevated
myself too hot
the um when you compare that with like a
reggae reggae sauce
there's so much more sugar in one of
those it's mad and you think hang on i
could
i could probably have another 50 of this
meal if i got rid of that sauce
so nando's sauce looking at some
different types of quark flavored quark
it'll be in
one side of the yogurt aisle in your
local supermarket
and charity popcorn i think those are my
those are my hats yeah i'm on those as
well i i think yeah
popcorn is one that i love because it's
just you can just
have such a it seems like such a big
amount of food that you're eating and
obviously
the most of it yeah it's like fruit
in a way that once you chew obviously
fruit will just turn into
disintegrated with mush yeah and and
popcorn just disintegrates yeah if you
took one bit of popcorn chewed it you're
like
what where is that where's it even
swallowing yeah i know what you mean um
but yeah there's some good
good fiber in there as well so yeah yeah
i i agree with those
one hundreds if you've got your stamp of
approval i'll take that what about
what are some of the ways that people
can improve their energy expenditure if
they're sedentary for most of the day
a lot of us are still working from home
perhaps we don't even have a commute to
work
maybe we've still got limited access to
a gym
what are some of the easy ways that
people can improve their
their need yes the neat so
that accounts for around about 15 of
your total daily energy
expenditure for most people so it's
something we don't even think about
like what we're doing here fidgeting
using our hands moving our lips
that's classed as neat um so yeah i mean
walking technically isn't neat but it
kind of is
you know it's not planned exercise like
okay it is planned exercise but let's
not get pedantic
let's include walking and meat so things
like
impr you know increasing number of steps
each day you know
if you're able to walk that is easy
that's an easy thing it doesn't require
you to do burpees doesn't require you to
to lift weights if you're not
comfortable doing that um
and even like tasks like gardening and
doing laundry all these kind of things
and a lot of people obviously been more
centrally over locked down because
they've been working from home
or on furlough but at work
depending on your occupation if you are
a nurse i mean
being in hospitals the amount of walking
you have to do
because they're large buildings between
area to area is
massive before you know it they could be
doing like 15 20 000 steps on a shift
um you just don't know and but another
person
their mate could be kind of on the same
calorie spectrum for maintenance they
think
but they're actually sitting around all
day so
their mate who's a nurse walking around
or whoever it is who's just
the guy the guy that works reception
versus the girl that's got to go and do
the thing they've been on the same shift
for the same amount of time
but one's moved fifteen thousand steps
and the others moved three thousand
yeah and it all adds up it seems so
insignificant because the
effort to walk that slow pace
or move or get up off the couch is a lot
lower than
doing a burpee for example but over time
yeah it will just pick it up so your bmr
is around 70
of your daily energy expenditure for
most people
which is just by breathing and a lot of
people don't realize that a lot of
people
with these apps that are around now are
kind of it's measuring the calories
burned which
is always going to be inaccurate and
they're kind of asking
do i need to deduct that from my
calories target it's like no
you just need to get a calorie
calculator that asks you about your
activity level and it will
tell you your calorie target based on
your activity so you just have to
focus on that one number you don't need
to do any calculations after that um
yeah we discussed the thermic effect
which is about 10 of your daily intake
just from food be higher if you consume
more protein or lower if you
consume virtually no protein and then
that leaves five percent for
planned exercise unless you're doing
intense exercise for like
four hours a day like triathlons if
you're like ross edgely swimming the
north sea or something
then that's gonna be a lot higher and i
think someone like him would need
like 10 000 calories or something a day
just to maintain that
um so yeah increasing neat going on
walks with mates
um taking up hobbies walking dogs
all these kind of things all add up
because we're too sedentary really um
as you know you've got netflix you've
got
tv with thousands of channels you've got
everything there you've got social media
all of which requires you to be still
when you're kind of looking at
it so it's kind of getting out of that a
little bit and just
moving a little bit more my so to speak
my spine coach dr stu mcgill he gives
all of his patients this is a spinal
input because locomotion lubricates the
spine in a way which actually reduces
back pain
as long as you're swinging your arms um
so you need that contra movement so that
you're doing this your hips are going
one way your shoulders are going another
but he prescribes after every meal do a
15 minute walk
and when you actually put that together
if you're moving an all right pace
that's your 10 000 steps and a bit
that's more than 10 000 steps within 45
minutes if you're moving an alright pace
yeah i mean yeah absolutely and there's
things you can do it's not just
like you know if you live in an area
which is boring scenery
is you just have to walk you can listen
to podcasts
music this one yeah that's right
obviously and then
you know you can even you know if you're
someone who talks to your mates on the
phone i don't think i've ever talked to
a mate on the phone since like 2008
the most anti-social person just like
text me or go away
but yeah if you're if you're chatting
away for an hour about something walk
around when you're doing it
like i think i have like a nervous thing
when i speak someone on the phone and
when i'm indoors i just walk around
dude sorry i'm doing it let me tell you
about that so
i got this insight from
who wrote becoming a supper leopard he's
been on this podcast oh god
yes i have he's got a girl's name
i can't remember people scrolling kelly
sterett
thank god yes that would have
annihilated me for the rest of the night
yeah i know hey kelly i'm sorry mate um
he said humans are locomotive beings
and he asks us to think about the last
time we had a phone call that required a
high level of cognitive load
so you're having a conversation with
your business partner about the
marketing copy for a new website right
what's that what's the tagline going to
be
and naturally you can't do it sat down
you have to get up and you have to move
and his argument is that it's something
to do with how our movement facilitates
our brain
it's not just a nervous twitch it's not
start trying to get rid of energy it's
facilitating the thinking process itself
and when you think about the fact that
every
great thinker that i admire from history
albert einstein newton darwin
all of these people decided to go for
walks
super regularly they were avid walkers
and
one of the reasons for that is it's not
it's not just the neat effect it's not
just improving your fitness
it's about what you can do mentally when
you're doing the work so dude i'm
i'm all for it that's probably for a
different discussion but that's
absolutely as important despite all of
this kind of fat loss
talk mental health is has to be the
number one
doesn't it so when we're talking about
all these benefits of compositional
change
the end goal is to make somebody happier
if they don't think any of this will
make them happier they don't have to do
it
it's as simple as that i love it yeah
dude where should people go they want to
check out your stuff
so probably the best place to be
instagram and it's just
the fitness chef on there um i've also
got a website called
fitnessdeaf.uk and on there um
what design is basically like a tool for
people who want to track their fitness
journey we're currently going through a
bit of an update to the app at the
moment
and on there they can track their food
there's lots of
uh calorie counted recipes on there soon
they'll be able to do a few other things
which i'll disclose soon
um and they can have a free trial so
yeah that's that's probably
the two best places facebook um tick
tock those kind of things i'm
i'm on but i'm not great at
is anyone great at tick tock unless
you're a dancer i don't think anyone's
great at tick tock yeah i i had a few
videos late last year that
went well you know getting a lot of
views and then decided to put
myself in a lot more of them and they
went terribly so i don't know
but then a few last week i decided to do
my infamous
avocado nutella post and just do a 30
second voiceover
describing in basic terms what i'm
saying and it's gone mental yeah and
then i did
an easter egg recipe like chocolate
moose died
died a horrible death so you just don't
know what's going on in there which
makes it exciting but because it's the
chinese
man when they're they're observing you
they've they've heard that last night
you criticized the communist regime and
then they pressed the button that
yeah nukes your account for the next
week man uh today's been awesome anybody
that wants to check out your stuff it'll
be linked below you need to give this
guy a follow on instagram
and yeah man let's think about something
else get yourself into more hot water
with someone and we'll
we'll bring you back on i'll be
delighted to come back so thanks for
inviting me take care
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy indeed
peace